كبيره جدا خاصه وسط المثقفين اكثر الكتاب
كتب بلغه يعني صعبه شيء ما على على عامه
الناس ولكن بالنسبه للطبقه النخبه
السياسيه وهي نخبه عريضه في السودان من
قديم
الكتاب اثار ضجه وصار حوار واسع جدا لانه
لاول مره كما قلت الادب كله صحيح ولكن كيف
يصنع القرار داخل اروقه الانقاذ كيف يدار
هذا المطبخ الخلافه السياسي والصراع الذي
كان مكتوما الى انفجر في المفاصل الشهيره
انا حاولت ان اكون موضوعيا جدا وان اركز
على تحول الافكار وتطورها اكثر من التركيز
على الاشخاص ولكن طبعا كانت هناك شخصيات
محوريه لعبت ادوار خطيره ادت انحراف
المشروع
وكان لابد من الاشاره اليها ولذلك مس
الكتاب عصب دقيق ومن شخص كان فعلا داخل
هذه الاروقه من هو كان مراقبه لصيقا
وانا طبعا كاتب لا اقصد اقصد اذا كان مس
اشخاص معينين داخل ربما هذه الجماعه وداخل
السلطه خاصه انت تحدثت عن اسماء معينه كما
تقول
كان اكثر تركيز على الشخص الذي احتكر
السلطه بالكامل في العامين الاولين
الانقاذ العام الذي كان فيه الترابي في
المعتقل سته اشهر في كوبر السجن المشهور
وسته اشهر في البيت ثم بعد ذلك تعرض لحادث
في كندا فكان هنالك عامين يحكم فيهما
السيد علي عثمان محمد طه حكما مطلقا كان
حاكما مطلقا بالفعل على على الجيش وعلى
الامن وعلى السياسه وعلى الاقتصاد او كان
بمثابه
خميني في تلك الفتره